using YouTube to brand your business so
I got a great question from one of my
patreon supporters dan winegar love you
guys
Pat runs a new service that I signed up
with and he wrote in to say hi Evan I'd
love to see a video on branding or using
videos and YouTube to brand your small
business so I'm a big I'm a big fan of
YouTube and big fan of music videos and
YouTube has become my favorite social
media network when I wake up every
morning they go to my computer or grab
my lentils or in this case because I'm
sick I'm grabbing my honey tea and my
Mickey Mouse cup and I look at my
youtube comments and why I love video is
it's a great way for your prospects and
for your customers to connect to you if
you want people to buy it from you
compared to your competition especially
going up against big competitors the
difference is gonna be your story right
why should I buy from you over everybody
else it's because you have a passionate
story
right you believe in something special
right and if I can feel that coming
through the video if I can watch your
video and feel connected to you I'm much
more likely to buy from you I people who
meet me at events who you know if I'm
walking down the street they'll come up
to me and they'll say hey Evan and
they'll they know me right and they know
all stuff about me until it was a little
scary to start but it's because I share
a lot through my videos people feel like
they have a personal connection to me
even though I'm I have no idea who they
are and it's an opportunity that this is
how you can stand out as an entrepreneur
is to tell your story and show your
passions now whatever business you're in
you're doing it because you're excited
about it right you have a deep passion
for it's not just to make money if it is
you gotta switch out and start a new
business but you know if you if you love
gardening that's your thing you know you
love gardening and used to do with your
mom when you were young and
you know garden is how you stay calm and
it's it's your former meditation and you
love helping people with their gardens
and when you start talking about
gardening your face lights up you get
all excited that's what I need to see
because when I come to your website it's
gonna be boring right your website looks
like every other website so so I've no
reason to buy from you over everybody
else I'm just gonna see okay who's the
lowest-cost I'm gonna go with that
person
but if you come across with the video
and share your personal story as to why
you started this why it means so much to
you not not a not a sales promo video
okay I don't need to be sold they'll
tell me the five reasons why you're
better than everybody else make a video
that tells me about you and why you're
so passionate about gardening or about
whatever it is that you do that comes
across and when I'm comparing you to
other people I'm gonna saying wow I
really I need to work with this person
because they really love what they're
doing I feel like I'm gonna get good
service I feel like you're gonna do a
good job right I remember having a
somebody call in to my radio show who
was a landscaper what they said was they
started landscaping because they they
want to create a nice community and they
treat each law that they landscape like
it was his mother's and he's really
emotional for me landscape ins whatever
but for him landscaping is like that
that is a huge deal and so have it
imagine that so good so I need someone
to come Alliance again need someone to
cut my grass okay I don't look at
university kids college kids high school
kids whoever's gonna spend you know 20
bucks come and cut my lawn why am I
gonna pay you you know forty bucks to do
it but you coming across and sharing
that story and telling me that you're
gonna treat my property like it was your
mother's property without kind of care
and love I'm gonna sign up with you like
that's who I want to work with I want to
work with people who are passionate what
they're doing are you gonna attract a
better clientele they're gonna spend
more money with you they're gonna refer
more business to you it's your biggest
single competitive advantage as an
entrepreneur is to tell your story and
so many people do such a bad
job of it so homework is get in front of
a camera you know use your laptop I'm
usually set up with my with all my gear
and everything but today I'm feeling
sick so I'm just I'm in front of my Mac
air I'm just sitting in front of my
computer and recording videos it doesn't
have to be complicated doesn't have to
be high budget start recording the video
and just tell me your story tell me why
you're doing this business and why it
means so much to you and imagine you
sitting across from somebody who's
asking you just like that so why did you
start this up and tap into some passion
and it may take you 50 takes to get
something that you like and you still
may not like it but put it up because
people watching that they feel your love
they're gonna sign up with you and as
maybe as a bonus then I know it's hard I
know you're stepping outside your
comfort zone I know it's challenging and
and the scary stuff you don't want to do
you know it's it's too far outside your
comfort zone but you know you want to
have success you gotta be able to step
outside your comfort zone and do
something a little scary sometimes so as
an added bonus for anybody who takes
that challenge who makes a video after
watching this video tells her story and
we'll watch it personally and give you
my feedback on what I think about it to
make it better okay that's a good
challenge it's a good fork believe those
are you watching you can subscribe to my
channel by clicking on there should be a
box coming up here you can support me or
click on the link in the description and
become a PadFone supporter just like
Darren was fast this question and leave
a comment let me know what you think I
love your comments coming in they mean a
lot to me and so I always appreciate
those so thank you guys and I'll see you
soon